My mother in law invited us over for a July 4th pool party.
So I decided to make something festive.
A flag cake.
People always ask me how we eat when we're in social settings.
And the truth is, my family eats the way we do.
We are always sharing our health earnings
and collaborate in the kitchen.
There's a health epidemic in our nation
because of the foods we consume.
And that's why I choose to make my foods from scratch.
Because then I can choose the ingredients we eat
rather than be unaware. Take Ein Korn,
for example. This flower is a health food.
The most primitive form of wheat known to man.
It doesn't upset stomachs because it's in its original form.
Some won't like that
it isn't the same as white flour from Modern Wheat,
but some will praise that.
Every cake I've ever seen is loaded with white sugar and white flour.
So while homemade is better,
it's still not ideal if it's high in sugar and refined carbs.
They've let us to believe that we can't do it.
We can't make it. It must be store bought.
I implore you to throw out that narrative.
You can make it, you should make it.
Food impacts our health. It impacts every part of our lives.
All this to say
that's why I made this cake and why I share it with my family.